the daily Vlogs are in 2015 I think yeah
and I was cognizant of this when I was
making it but it's like I'm I have a
daily record of my life it's like pretty
well produced yeah oh yeah of my whole
life and I was like Someday I'm gonna
look back at this yeah and it's going to
be interesting but I've always been so
close to it then last week when elon's
rocket [__] exploded or whatever my
buddy texted me he's like we gotta go
see it next time have you ever seen a
like a rocket have you guys ever seen a
[__] rocket person you have yeah I
grew up in Florida so we're ready Life
Changes yeah it's crazy like when you
look at it there's a [__] human in
there yeah and I went for the last space
shuttle Blast Off ever it was like a
dream of mine I grabbed my girlfriend we
drove down there like a Winnebago and we
watched it in 2013. yeah and I made a
movie it was like the trip where I fell
in love with her and like we're like
married now a bunch of kids and stuff
but I was like playing that back just
trying to find the scene where the
rocket blasts off for that moment and
like I watched the whole like 10 minutes
I'm like sitting there crying because
it's like we're like dating we're like
young and I was like oh [__] that thing
where I looked back at it and I'm able
to see my life in such like such a vivid
portrayal like that's happened it's like
having a wedding video for every single
day yeah three years instead of it being
just like a [__] terrible wedding
video
it's like an interesting reminder of the
happiest day of your life
there's there's a video you put out
recently
that I was watching I thought it was
very good very uh very introspective and
what what something you struggle with
which was the inauthenticity of living
through a vlog
um yeah yeah and how that kind of pulled
at you at the end of those 800 days
where you're like am I ever present or
am I always thinking about the video
and one thing that I thought really
separated you from the other people who
copied you was well one story but we can
get to that later you actually
understand story but but also
authenticity you are incredibly
comfortable talking to a camera it feels
like you're talking to me and I do not
like doing that [__] I hate it I I don't
know I think for some reason I don't
connect it to I don't know what the [__]
it is but but when do you start to feel
yourself almost doing is it an
impression of yourself why do you feel
inauthentic what I don't know like the
Vlog particularly like uniquely was
it was about my life like every day I
just sort of pull interestingness from
my life
and if you start to examine your life
from like a third person perspective
it's really interesting for a while like
the place where you go and I don't mean
I live a particularly interesting life I
just mean like I go to this place and
get a smoothie I know the owner we say
what's up like I know I've got friends
like it's interesting you have to see
some but like that works for like
a couple days
the next
797 years you've got to promote
something fresh and like so like that
starts to fade and you start to feel it
being repetitive and you get insecure
and those sort of like those very
introspective insecurities really start
to build over time so then you start to
seek interestingness elsewhere and I
think this is like this is why we've
seen rise and fall of so many YouTubers
it's like okay I need to be more
interesting like let me Rush towards
sensationalism yeah like you know it's
interesting a car accident you know it's
interesting like anything extreme like
that's so let me Rush towards that I
never wanted to do that ever like none
of that I did not want to seek
sensationalism so you just start pulling
you start creating and all of a sudden
yeah you start to feel a little bit of
you're like playing a character of
yourself
and that was tough like confronting that
was tough so instead of living your life
and then making content about it you're
like yo how can I live my life in a way
that makes interesting content and that
felt inauthentic to you okay there were
weird like um
unintended consequences though I was
thinking about this a lot this morning I
might run particularly this morning I
was so drilled in on this my wife and I
were fighting about something yesterday
and this is what I was thinking about
my wife is the most amazing character on
camera because she gives zero [__] she
does not give a [__]
and like a lot of like partners and
YouTube Vlogs were always like hey what
are you doing you know it's a very very
turned up you're like I've met a lot of
people never met a human that's actually
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is an
inconvenience to her she doesn't give a
[__] and no matter what yeah she'd say
something interesting but please say it
again like you can go [__] yourself
I'm gonna use that yeah um
but I remember vividly like I needed her
so much for those moments that when we
get in actual fights
I'd be like
I can't afford this fight right now I
can't afford this fight right now wow
and that sounds like a little bit evil
and awful but I think there's another
side to it which is like what you're
married like you know like you get into
a fight over [__] [__] and if you
step away and you're like you know if
something were to happen if lightning
were to strike tonight would I give a
[__] about this what we're fighting
about like no this is meaningless it's
stupid just put it just push it aside
and love her yeah and like the Vlog in
its most virtuous take forced me to do
that with her like I couldn't let the
[__] Fester yeah
which sounds virtuous but I couldn't let
the [__] Fester because I needed her
to make my [__] video yeah but the
alcohol but the outcome was the same and
I think about that now because that
thing that I was thinking about that we
were fighting about in the like this
morning is that I literally like didn't
put the dishes in the dishwasher last
night yeah and I'm like you know if I
don't want to [__] put them in the
dish I'm gonna put them in the Pocket
Edition
I'm not you know who pays for the maid I
pay for the maids
this place works
why do they love that so much what is it
what is it about women when you tell
them that you provide a particularly
yeah and if that doesn't work you just
you say you know what you're acting like
your mother right now yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the thing is she's always right yes and
I am the problem I acknowledge that yeah
instead of couples therapy just started
vlogging that will save you man yeah you
know it's like there is genuine truth
behind that outrageous did you ever give
her bad edits because you were annoying
no
honestly it was the always the other way
around it's like she would always like
when I would look back at the footage I
would always realize how [__] wrong I
was
like [__] and I have to like sweeten
myself up in the edit because she's
always right yeah she's like a very kind
smart beautiful loving I'm like a
[__] monster so you're doing retakes
on green screen you're like I love you
babe
what I'm curious what kept you away from
sensationalism if all these other
YouTubers are going down that track was
it the Detachment from the data or the
monetization or was it just a dedication
to the art
um
you know it's more just like watching my
peers do that and just such [__]
disgust and that's not a judgment on
everyone but like I want like my little
daughter she's eight now she's not so
little but like when she's on YouTube
unsupervised yeah then we have her
[__] iPad all right iPad locked up
but she's smarter than us yeah you can
put all these filters on it and [__]
she's figured out all she has to do is
sign out of iCloud and all the filters
disappear there's no beating her yeah
um when no one's looking she's watching
these family vlogs
and like it's the grossest [__] you've
ever seen and it's like really yucky I
hate it and everything's like wow what
are we gonna do guys and it's like let's
go throw Mommy's car in the river and
it's like this [__] just lunacy yeah
and it was so gross that I had this
tremendous insecurity that I'd ever get
even close even near that yeah because
like make no mistake like I'm an ABS
like I am a YouTuber I'm a vlogger I
make videos about myself yeah they're
very self-centered they're very like
self-aggrandizing like it's me talking
to a camera with the like presumption
that the world gives a [__] about what I
think like I don't hide from any of that
but there's still a little thread that
like I like to think of myself as like a
filmmaker or storyteller and so it's
like a there I've got that insecurity on
one side and that that driving like
desire to still maintain some of that
filmmaker you know Integrity on the
other and I think it's a needle that
sometimes I've read well and other times
I don't